feeding time in the rainforest in the
Congo Basin one after another the
gorillas climb into the trees desirable
fruits grow in the forest canopy
gorillas are vegetarians Thomas poya has
studied these primates for many years
his face mask protects the Apes from
infectious human diseases Ohio knows the
gorillas need the forest just as much as
the forest needs the guerrillas
guerrillas happen the gorillas are very
important for the rainforest because
they spread the seeds of the fruits they
eat and contribute to regenerating all
the vegetation some flan see that it's
all the African rainforest is important
for the Earth's climate it stores huge
amounts of carbon dioxide preserving it
is the aim of a try national project
between Cameroon the Republic of the
Congo and the Central African Republic
about 25,000 square kilometers of forest
have been declared a conservation zone
Ilana ladean is responsible for
coordinating the project's development
on site many regions can be reached only
by boat
we're on the Sangha River which crosses
the Tri National Conservation Area it's
in the heart of the Congo Basin and
plays an important role in preserving
the climate undergo an exception if the
Amazon rainforest is the first then the
Congo Basin could be called the planets
second lung planet he still has a lot of
convincing to do most people on the
edges of the conservation area see the
park as more of a threat excuse all
responsible according to the discussions
we've had since the parks creation the
numbers of wild animals marilla's
chimpanzees and elephants have increased
the damage to the fields here has put
people's survival at risk at all that's
why they expect compensation from the
park so they can survive in their
villages
buffer zones around the conservation
area are meant to provide revenue to the
communities there they can fell trees
and sell the timber Germany alone has
allocated about 30 million euros to
protect this unique habitat because
preserving the rainforests in the Congo
Basin is decisive in the battle against
climate change faced with massive
poaching in the conservation zone the
three African countries have formed a
wildlife protection troop it patrols the
border area to combat the trade in ivory
and live animals
since 2012 the entire conservation area
has been a UNESCO World Heritage Site
it's an important if partial victory
increasing the chances that at least
part of the congos green lungs of the
world will be saved from total
exploitation